public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
michel sapin le ministre de l'économie
et des finances est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir messieurs
ministre merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez vous donc de public sénat avec
les échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse bien sûr vous allez réagir
dans quelques secondes aux derniers
chiffres du chômage fin septembre il est
bon un fort recul
après cela il y aura trois grandes
questions pour vous est ce que vous
prétendez toujours où plus que jamais ce
soir avoir redressé l'économie vous
répondrez à jean francis pécresse
françois hollande doit-il renonçait à se
présenter en 2017 il n'y a pas que
l'économie il ya également les faits
livre vous le savez vous répondrais la
lucide malandain enfin et si la droite
et le centre avaient le remède ou les
remèdes vous évoquerez avec michael ms
la primaire de la droite et du centre
donc mais d'abord bien sûr la question
d'actualité ce soir pour l'emploi vient
de publier les chiffres de septembre
avec une donc une baisse importante 60
3300 après la très forte hausse et
enregistreront s'en souvient au mois
d'août
c'est un effet de balancier bien sûr que
vous savourez ce soir est ce que vous
avez une explication à ce chiffre
je crois qu'il vaut éviter les
expressions du genre savourer ou être
jovial parce qu'il ya un chiffre qui est
un très bon chiffre
un mois le mois précédent il était de
moins bonne qualité était même à
linverse a d'ailleurs été saluée si je
puis dire par l'ensemble des
commentateurs sur le thème terrible
l'affreux épouvantable aujourd'hui je
n'emploierai pas des termes inverses
calme en cours un chiffre qui est
devenue en quelques chiffres en main
parce que moi je connais bien ces
mécanismes de chiffres mensuels du
chômage
j'étais ministre du travail jean connaît
à la fois la pertinence parce que ça
indique des choses et en même temps j'en
connais la volatilité vous n'avez
réaction quand je regarde une chose je
regarde une seule chose que s'est il
passé au cours des derniers mois que
s'est il passé par exemple depuis le
début de cette année est-ce que
trimestre par trimestre ne prenons pas
mois par mois parce que c'est un six
mois par mois
enfin je devrais dire c'est ainsi mois
par mois
mais est ce que au cours de ces trois
derniers trimestres est ce que le
chômage a baissé
c'est le troisième trimestre consécutif
avec les trois derniers mois où le
chômage baisse en france s'est défait je
ne dis pas qu'il faut s'en réjouir ou
qu'il faut s'en satisfaire
définitivement mais les faits c'est que
le chômage a baissé ou titre des
chiffres de pôle emploi depuis le début
de cette année est ce que ça va se
poursuivre en ce moment là ce sont juste
pour que les gens aient de la charente
est ce que ça reste pour 90 mille
chômeurs de moins depuis le début
d'année
on est dans la rejoint cela rejoint un
autre type de chiffres seront toujours
les gens s'ils perdent là dedans qu'est
le chiffre international le chiffre des
comparaisons internationales
c'est le chiffre qui est établi par
l'insee avec des règles dites du bureau
international du travail
et ces chiffres là qui ont été
d'ailleurs cité dans un débat qui avait
lieu juste avant cette émission sont des
chiffres qui indiquent depuis un an le
chômage baisse en france le pourcentage
de chômeurs par rapport à la population
active ne cesse de baisser depuis alors
très bon le dire simplement et le
chômage baisse
clairement en france depuis un an et vos
derniers chiffres qui viennent d'arriver
confirme cette évolution à la baisse du
cac baisse est ce que c'est l'inversion
de la courbe annoncé si je devais
reprendre cette expression qui
maintenant est totalement dévaloriser
puisqu'elle a été utilisée réutiliser au
commentaire critique et la vérité c'est
que quand le chômage baisse depuis un an
ça doit s'appeler une courbe inversée du
chômage mais laissons cela de côté
je pense que pour les français c'est
presque plus compréhensible ainsi et
c'est comme ça je l'espère que pour ceux
qui retrouvent de l'emploi ils le vivent
le chômage baisse en france depuis un an
c'est clair net et précis et toutes les
statistiques vont dans le même les
chiffres car il a sur un quinquennat sur
le quinquennat il augmentait de combien
si je me prenais une catégorie les
jeunes parce qu'on est toujours à se
préoccuper à juste titre du chômage déjà
un petit plus élevé que le chômage de
manière générale est ce que le nombre
des jeunes aujourd'hui au chômage le
nombre des jeunes aujourd'hui au chômage
est supérieur ou inférieur au nombre des
joueurs au chômage au début de ce
quinquennat rive est donc inférieur il
est inférieur aux aimé qui le dit qui le
commande ce chiffre là qui est
indubitable 1
duby table après si vous prenez le
nombre global des chômeurs dans les
catégories à partir du plus âgé il est
aujourd'hui encore plus élevé cantonnera
au début de cette formule élevé qu'aux
débuts au plus élevé qu'au début la
population active a elle-même aussi
augmenté nous avons une un pays qui a
une caractéristique est une bonne chose
c'est qu'ils arrivent sur le marché du
travail tous les ans plus de personnes
que ce qu'on attend alors mais non bien
sûr c'est pas le cas en allemagne
c'est pas le cas en espagne ans c'est
pas le faire oui pmi graphique donc
c'est pas bien sûr il ya une carrière de
vérifier et on sent pris fait que nous
devons en france créé plus d'emplois
qu'ailleurs pour faire récupérer le
givrage cousin connaissent donc avec
toutes les précautions d'usagé les
rappelle que vous venez de faire qu'il
ya inversion de la courbe vous l'avez
dit michel sapin est ce que françois
hollande a tenu sa promesse
or vous vous aimez vous pose la question
vous dit c'est qu'il a dit là tu
désormais comme ça on ne fait pas des
promesses d'inversion de courbes de
chiffres on promet pas des chiffres on
est on s'engage à faire tout ce qu'il
est possible pour faire en sorte que le
chômage baisse
il a fait beaucoup je sais pas si c'est
tout ce qui est possible tout ça peut se
discuter il a fait beaucoup
nous avec au gouvernement chacun dans
son pote j'étais au travail avant je
suis aujourd'hui à l'économie et aux
finances donc de votre bus et les deux
les deux aspects qui permettent de faire
baisser le chômage et donc le chômage
baisse certains diront enfin mais baisse
aujourd'hui clairement en france chacun
avec les inquiétudes pour la croissance
non parce qu'enfin non la couronne
vautours dans les inquiétudes sur la
croissance mais nous avons vécu avec
depuis 2007 avec des croissances qui
sont à zéro ou en dessous de zéro avec
ça vous ne créez pas de chaume de
d'emplois et donc à créer du chômage
nous vivons depuis l'année dernière avec
une croissance supérieure à 1 % avec
plus de 1% en france dans le contexte
actuel y arriver on peut créer
suffisamment d'emplois pour faire
reculer dernière question est ce que ce
chiffre n'est pas aussi l'effet du
nombre des formations certaines
fantaisiste nous dit-on d'ailleurs un
qui a été porté à 1 million par françois
hollande qui est donc
sociaux les personnes à bord alors une
question et le mois dernier c'était
l'effet des formations donc à chaque
fois que fallait il ya un rush
manifestement jamais pour pour qu'il y
ait de plus en plus de demandeurs
d'emploi en formation en c'est la loi
qui a un bon chiffre
comme personne ne veut accepter qu'ils
puissent y avoir de bons chiffres
on essaye de trouver une mauvaise raison
à ce bon chiffre
il n'y a pas de mauvaises raisons à ce
bon chiffre est un certain nombre de
raisons il y à des formations
supplémentaires
c'est fait pourquoi ces formations
supplémentaires certains disent c'est
pour masquer le chiffre voyons si on
peut toujours dire n'importe quoi ces
faits allait reposer la question à ceux
qui sont dans ces formations
c'est fait pour permettre à des gens qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage de trouver
un emploi qui par ailleurs est vacant
parce que c'est quand même une situation
incroyable dans notre économie
il y à des emplois proposés par des
entreprises des employeurs et où ils ne
trouvent pas l'antenne de ces formations
sont vraiment ses blessures vers 23 ses
cinq sens là je sais aussi parce que
j'ai commencé ce programme là il était
commencée au niveau de deux cent mille
aujourd'hui il est à ce jour le niveau
de 500000 c'est calibré pour des
formations correspondant à des besoins
dans chacune des régions concernées et
s'est fait aussi par les partenaires
sociaux
il raconte pas n'importe quoi les
patrons ils vont pas financer parce
qu'il participe au financement des
formations qui ne servent à rien donc
deux formations qui sont utiles pour
trouver un emploi
ce qui est évidemment le seul objectif
qu'on doit avoir voilà votre réaction
donc à ce chiffre important du jour la
suite tout de suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec la question que vient vous
poser jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique
l'épreuve de vérité
avec ray du classique et les échos
bonsoir agents français sont soir michel
bonsoir michel sapin alors il y a un bon
chiffre du chômage qui est tombé ce soir
mais au-delà de ce chiffre là il ya le
bilan économique de ce quinquennat
croissance très faible très très faible
à peine plus de 1 % en 2016 à peine plus
de 1% en 2010 est peut-être il y à
chômage quand même + 6 600 mille
chômeurs de plus depuis mai 2012
quand nos voisins font beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
il ya la dette publique 98 5 % de la
richesse il ya le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires qui est un qui est à un
niveau absolument record est ce que vous
espérez convaincre les français que vous
avez redresser l'économie française tel
que présenté par vous y compris avec les
inexactitudes que cela comporte
alors qu'elle inexactitudes et y compris
des inexactitudes que cela comporte et
sans élément de comparaison avec ce qui
pouvait se passer autrefois la taille et
la masse est dit si je puis me permettre
la messe est dite à la messe est dite
tel que vous le présentez bien donc on
va essayer de reprendre les choses aussi
un peu tels que telles qu'elles sont
quand on veut regarder quel est le
chemin parcouru par un gouvernement et
par une majorité il vaut mieux parti de
savoir de loups d'où on part et j'espère
que vous ne considérez pas que la france
en 2012 et est en situation
exceptionnelle
si je prenais les chiffres que vous
venez d'avancé qu'ils sont des chiffres
pour certains d'entre eux exact pour
d'autres contestables
est ce que le déficit public en france
en 2012 était supérieur à celui
d'aujourd'hui ou pas ils étaient
supérieurs largement inférieurs il a
donc diminué vous est-ce que la dsg team
2012 le ramener à 3% d'une fibre edel en
2013 est-ce que la dette la dette était
à 80 6% avec les dom et à la valeur des
ventes en hausse de 5 ans vous l'avez
augmenté de 4,5 milliards d'euros de
ventes en l'espace de cinq ans de vous
n'avez pour des métaux crise et comment
il est mort quand ça plus souvent avec
la manière
présenter les choses c'est tout ce que
je m'y attendais c'est plutôt vous
interrompt la manière vous avez présenté
les choses tendent les ondes de radio
classique
intéressant donc lag la dette avait
explosé de 25 points de pib entre 2007
et 2012
elle a augmenté de 7 points de pib entre
2012 et aujourd'hui c'est peut-être trop
vous pouvez me fait cette critique bien
c'est trop s'en crée c'est qu'elle est
stabilisé oui elle est aujourd'hui
stabilisé aux alentours de 96 80 18 les
derniers chiffres et que vous le savez
pas ce que vous êtes un bon spécialiste
des drogba sera d'ici à la fin de cette
année elle sera aux alentours de 96 % du
pipe donc nous avons stabilisé la dette
est ce que nous avons à ce que dans
l'économie mais c'est pas à nous c'est
des entreprises mais on crée quand même
une ambiance on crée aussi des outils
qui leur permet de faire cela parce que
les entreprises ont recommencé à créer
des emplois privés
je parle pas de ce qui peut se passer
dans les formations je ne passe pas deux
centenaires et non des bonbons 140001
défieurs donc bien entendu cette ceci ça
suffit à faire reculer le chômage
on le voit mais est-ce que ça suffit à
ce que dans la durée on puisse
considérer que la france a retrouvé une
situation de manière qui nous quitte
parfaitement satisfait évidemment dans
la question amusante et ça la question
finale donc depuis quand
n'avait-on pas créer 140 mille emplois
en un an bon depuis des années et des
années il faut remonter avant la crise
de 2007
bref je prends ces chiffres là pourquoi
quelque part c'est aussi la satisfaction
la situation d'aujourd'hui ne peut pas
être considérée comme satisfaisante
vous pouvez pas de satisfaits
définitivement d'une situation où il ya
encore autant de chômeurs vous ne pouvez
pas être satisfait d'une situation où
nous avons certes fait reculer de
déficit de la france derrière le déficit
et la dette moi c'est la seule chose qui
me préoccupe et la dette c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut rembourser c'est
quelque chose qui pèsent sur les
générations ça pèse sur vos enfants sur
les miens et sur mes petits enfants ou
sur les votre nom vous n'avez pas encore
des petits-enfants bien bref donc non
donc je ne veux pas de ça donc est-ce
que de ce point de vue là on a amélioré
les choses la réponse est oui
objectivement andrée nion regard des
choses alors ses dires agressée
on peut dire redresser est ce que c'est
on est au bout du chemin non est ce qui
a encore deux des progrès à faire c'est
évident est-ce qu'il ya encore des gens
malheureux en france si on a
considérablement qui sont malheureux en
france est ce qui a encore des choses à
faire pour les entreprises puisque c'est
aussi des sujets qui vous intéressent et
m'intéresse
la réponse et vous
nous avons fait le cic eux nous avons
fait ce qu'on appelle le pacte de
responsabilité donc des baisses de
charges
nous avons annulé la totalité des
augmentations de charges voter certes
par cette majorité mais votée par la
majorité précédente
donc on a fait un chemin absolument
considérable c'est dommage de ne pas
considérer ce chemin même si ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des critiques par
ailleurs mais c'est pour ça peut partir
d'une base objectifs permet d'avoir un
débat ensuite semble-t-il chelsea
l'allemagne sur la même période
exactement de mai 2012 à août 2016 fait
480 mille chômeurs de moins
l'espagne ont fait 1 million 400 mille
et le royaume uni ont fait plus de 1700
milles de moi qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché en france alors juste a aussi
quand on fait des comparaisons c'est
juste il faut faire pour savoir faire
des compagnes d'entre eux revient sur
l'allemagne ou prenez l'espagne
heureusement que nous ne sommes pas dans
la situation espagnole en france
aujourd'hui
heureusement la france on l'a d'espagne
ce serait le pays miraculeux
quel est le taux de chômage ils ont fait
chuter les taux de chômage 25 19 le taux
de chômage des jeunes dit il et il est
aux alentours de 50 concerts bref
heureusement que sopal en situation et
comme vous le savez la d'espagne n'a
toujours pas retrouvé aujourd'hui la
richesse de pipe comme on dit que qui
était le sien en 2007 donc j'ai
heureusement que ce n'est pas en espagne
et quand on est tombé très bas c'est
vrai qu'on reprenons l'allemagne parce
que là c'est évidemment comparable
sommes deux grandes économies nous
sommes beaucoup plus comparable où on
était l'allemagne en 2012 du point de
vue de ses finances publiques parce que
les finances lui que ça compte quand
vous avez des bonnes finances publiques
à l'aise si je puis dire vous pouvez
impulsé vous pouvez soutenir vous pouvez
faire en sorte que ce soit des finances
au service de la croissance où on est et
quel était le déficit la de l'allemagne
en 2002 0 là où nous étions à plus de 5%
de déficit zéro et où on l allemagne
aujourd'hui à zéro ou un peu plus
c'est à dire qu'elle n'a pas eu pendant
ces cinq ans à faire d'efforts
budgétaires elles l'avaient fait avant
elle avait fait avant avant 2012 elle
avait refait ce n'est pas obligé terre
et donc pendant toute cette période elle
a pu avoir une politique beaucoup plus
comme on dit dans le jargon des
économistes expansionniste là où la
langue
il a fallu certains nous critiquent en
disant que c'était une politique
d'austérité c'est pas vrai c'est
l'austérité ça c'est ce qui s'est passé
en espagne ou au portugal
mais nous il a fallu avoir une politique
sérieuse du point de vue budgétaire en
dessous d'ordre d'augmentation d'impôts
il ya rendre 5 me en augmentation de 7,1
grands sacs sont les deux cd de côté
donc c'est ce qu'avaient voté nicolas
sarkozy si je puis dire ce qui a été
voté depuis
sans compter qu'après la politique qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui qui est plus de
croissance
vous dites à peine 1% quand on est 1,3
pour cent c'était l'année dernière aux
alentours de 1 5% cette année et qu'on
recherche quelque chose qui est
largement supérieur à 1% pour l'année
prochaine les retours de 1,5 la peine
d'en recruter tout ça peut être risqué
on a retrouvé la croissance et c'est
cette croissance qui nous permet
aujourd'hui un de baisser les impôts et
charges et les impôts de faire face
aussi à des dépenses supplémentaires
parce que l on me dirait pas que la
france
du point de vue de la sécurité est
exactement dans la même situation que
celle de 2012 les attentats terroristes
la situation en syrie ou en irak n'était
pas exactement ce que la france avait en
face d'elle on est obligé ça peut aussi
y faire face et à la valeur eric woerth
était à votre place la semaine dernière
info le secrétaire général du parti des
républicains
c'est aujourd'hui en france le contraire
du redressement que vous revendiquez
donc ce soir dans l'épreuve de vérité
alors lui aussi il a des arguments quand
on regarde l'ensemble du bilan c c'est
au fond est-ce que la france la
progression ou pas est-ce qu'on est
encore plus heureux de vivre en france
cinq ans après est ce qu'on est fiers de
vivre dans notre pays
est ce qu'on a donné une vision et un
peu de perspectives à notre pays
à ces questions la réponse est non on a
bien du mal à rattraper
l'après crise en termes de pouvoir
d'achat les déficits publics s'améliore
à la vitesse de la tortue les systèmes
le système social n'est pas équilibré
bref on a perdu sur beaucoup de deux
tableaux michel sapin cette opinion elle
est aussi le reflet de ce qu'une grosse
majorité de français pense quand on les
interroge ils jugent votre bilan
économique de manière extrêmement sévère
est ce qu'ils se trompent quand woerth
tient ces propos je les tiens des propos
d'opposants je veux pas lui faire aux
proches de tenir des propos d'opposants
et vous même un jeu peut-être les
cheveux aussi lâché les faits quand les
déficits passait de 2 5% avec lui
d'ailleurs aux manettes budgétaire à
plus de 5%
donc je trouve que simplement quand on
est opposant vous appeliez il vaut
tellement le en faire plus encore de
déficit mieux pardon mieux plus encore
mieux
donc quand on est opposant est normal de
critiquer c'est le rôle mais je pense
pour le faire avec une certaine modestie
qui consisterait à se rappeler ce qui
s'est exactement passé quand on était
soit même aux responsabilités ça vaut
pour tout le monde pour le passé comme
je pourrais vous dire à la crise de 2008
n'a pas été en crise en 2011 en 2012 ou
en 2013
l'europe se passe pause c'était
merveilleux de tout se passait bien il a
créé 10 au laurie européens l'allemagne
l'an passé dominique a fait la preuve
zone euro elle-même et un oedème grande
situation de crise et heureusement
si nous voulons que la france et
l'allemagne ont fait ce qu'il fallait
pour que l'euro l'europe n'explose pas
en 2012
et dans ce qu'il fallait faire il y
avait en france une politique sur le
budget était une politique très
restrictive qui reste là encore les
économistes que j'appellerais mois une
politique sérieuse peut pas tout faire à
la fois on a fait cette politique
sérieuse ça nous a privé par rapport à
ce qu'ils puissent passer en allemagne
d'un certain nombre de moyens
budgétaires pour soutenir la croissance
puisque vous parlez budget précisément
votre majorité a adopté aujourd'hui même
la partie recettes du projet de budget
2010 est jeudi votre majorité mais en
réalité c'est une majorité sur laquelle
vous ne semblait plus avoir beaucoup de
prises puisque lors de cette discussion
on a vu le gouvernement clie être mise
en minorité par la gauche de votre
majorité sur un certain nombre de choses
sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières et sur la réforme des
actions gratuites le monde titrait hier
qu'il y avait dans cette discussion une
atmosphère de fin de règne
les journalistes aujourd'hui ils veulent
raconter une histoire
donc il raconte une histoire l'histoire
c'est que on y reviendra sûrement à
cause du livre etc
aujourd'hui il y aurait une forme de
déliquescence de la majorité je crois
que keira caricature pas par rapport à
l'histoire qui est un peu celle que vous
êtes en train de raconter
la semaine dernière j'étais c'est pas la
première fois que je défends un budget
et ce n'est pas la première fois que je
participe à un débat budgétaire nous
avons débattu nous avons parfois à
trouver avec notre majorité des éléments
de compromis positif je pense que vous
allez rappelé faire des articles sur le
fait que l'assemblée nationale a voté la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés en
france à 28% pour toutes les sociétés y
compris les plus grandes sur quatre ans
juste est ce que est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui a été fait par le
passé
est-ce que c'est nouveau ou pas est ce
que bon 28% est-ce que c'est moins qu'en
2012 c'est largement moins voir donc
voilà juste je veux dire que la majorité
c'est pas si simple que cela doit
débattre avec une majorité de gauche et
de lui faire partager l'idée suivant
laquelle c'est bon pour l'économie
française que l'impôt sur les sociétés
diminué en commençant par les plus
petites et que c'est ça qui nous
permettra aussi d'une certaine manière à
la fois d'attirer les investissements de
faire en sorte que de l'étranger ou en
france on investisse dans l'industrie ou
dans les services et capa ces deux là
ont créé des emplois
ça c'est ce qui a été acquis sur les
deux sujets que vous avez décrit que je
pas sûr que ça exprime aux yeux de tout
le monde
quelque chose de très précis mais sur la
taxe sur les transactions financières ou
sur ce qu'on appelle les aga les actions
gratuites l'année dernière sur la taxe
des transactions financières déjà cette
disposition avait été votée déjà avec la
réticence du gouvernement parce que je
disais si elle est votée elle sera
jamais appliquée parce que qu'on
sexuelle valve annulé il ce qui s'est
passé le conseil national l'a annulée
très bien ça revient dans les mêmes
conditions que les airs bref bref
et là vous aviez un démaquillant débat
démocratique est un débat où nous vous
acceptez les gouvernements et de temps
en temps ça me dire j'aurais chèque on
important au niveau de mes chiens et
plus si c'est m mais j'arrive pourquoi
vous en vous ne serez pas de gain de
cause devant votre majorité que vous
espérez sans doute obtenir gain de cause
demain lors du réexamen du texte avez
vous avez une étrange pardon de le dire
comme sa conception de la démocratie
parlementaire
si la démocratie parlementaire c'est un
gouvernement qui arrive avec quelque
chose qu'il impose et qui revient et
mais qui est adoptée de manière
totalement identique à la fin pardon
j'ai été pendant des années et des
années 5e mandat parlementaire c'est pas
comme ça même en 81
avec des majorités gigantesque que je
vois le débat pas fier à un débat il
peut être parfois vifs
il ya un débat parlementaire il a permis
sur certains points de faire évoluer les
choses mais souhaitait juste prendre un
chiffre le dernier chiffre mais si on a
eu beaucoup de chance juge de paix cet
après midi a eu lieu le vote sur la
première partie de l'audience c'est à
dire toutes les dispositions dont vous
n'êtes parler quel a été le sens de ce
vote
est ce qu'il ya eu plus ou moins de
votants pour cette année allez vous avez
obtenu une plus large majorité
voilà il est plus là c'est une
déliquescence de la majorité quand elle
est plus large pour adopter le texte
comme celui-ci voilà je voudrais juste
ramené à la boue de la juste proportion
la réalité des débats parlementaires qui
nous ont occupés au cours de ces
derniers jours
merci beaucoup jean-francis lucile
malanda de la lfp nous rejoint
effectivement vous avez raison michel
sapin on va reparler du livre je m'y
attendais il est prof de l'éviter avec
les bons soirs du c'est bon sens michel
beaucoup de sapins alors françois
hollande doit-il renoncé à se lancer
dans une nouvelle campagne
présidentielle on a vu que les nuages
s'amoncelaient sur son passage reste à
man
vous qui êtes très proche de lui qu'en
pensez vous proche ou pas proche ça
change pas grand chose en l'occurrence
on est dans le monde politique dans le
domaine politique
il est président de la république il
assume d'abord et avant tout les tâches
qui sont celles d'un président de la
république et il n'a pas à se laisser
troubler par tel ou tel commentaire par
telle parution tel ou tel livre tel ou
tel débat autour de la parution sony
même si ces débats sont par ailleurs
parfaitement géré son cabinet c'est
quand même lui qui parle dans les livres
il est passé mais je n'ai nulle part n'a
pas se laisser troubler par les débats
des petits ces débats sont parfaitement
légitimes donc et je veux y participer
si vous le souhaitez sur le bouquin lui
même mais il est présent appliquée doit
assumer pleinement et totalement ses
fonctions il a donné une orientation il
ya plusieurs mois de cela en disant je
dirais aux alentours de mi décembre
si je suis candidat ou si je ne suis pas
candidat
rien de ce point de vue là n'a changé
c'est un mi décembre que le président la
république actuel dira s'il a choisi et
pour quelles raisons s'il a choisi
d'être candidat on n'est pas candidat
juste pour le plaisir on est candidat
pour quelque chose
et espérer qu avant la fin de l'année
absolument persuadé que dans le contexte
actuel il est espéré que d'un coup il
allait retrouver ou trouvez pas ce que
vous regardez aussi les choses dans la
durée des niveaux de popularité et je
fais une grande différence ça aussi
c'est l'expérience entre ce qu'on
appelle la popularité est ce qu'on
appelle une intention de vote
c'est pas tout à fait de même nature
mais pas tout à fait de même nature
monde à l'attention de vote qui a un sol
déjà mais aujourd'hui les fassis nous
avons 80 dates gauche d'ailleurs ouais
enfin bon on peut toujours voir les
choses dans tous les sens donc
aujourd'hui la dispersion de la dhr je
finis sur le président la pique
je lui avais si j'avais un conseil à
l'idée puisque vous dites je suis proche
c'est vous avez donné monsieur le
président la république une indication
au 15 décembre c'est au 15 décembre ou
aux alentours du 15 décembre que vous
ferez connaître votre choix si j'avais
un deuxième conseil à lui donner
c'est qu'une candidature doit avoir un
sens on n'est pas candidat pour être
candidat ou on ne l'est pas pas candidat
si paisible
refuse d'être candidat il faut si on
refuse il faut il faut aussi que c'est
un sens on peut pas dire que donc il
faut qu'ils aient un sens à cela ait un
sens qui est par essence personnel qui
est pas celle à sens par rapport à
l'histoire par rapport à la france y
compris par rapport à la gauche ou par
rapport à quelle heure entre familles
politiques
et bien si on se présente c'est parce
qu'on pense que quand on peut continuer
à sa longue de choses mais surtout qu'on
peut mener des politiques qui soient des
politiques qui apporte au pays quelque
chose de nouveau
on n'est pas candidat pour rééditer on
n'est pas candidat pour refaire on n'est
pas quoi dire pour réparer on est
candidat pour construire quelque chose
ait quelque chose de nouveau dont la
france peut avoir mais il ya pas mal de
gens à gauche qui commence à lui dire
ben
c'est peut-être que justement pour le
bien de la gauche voire pour le bien de
la france on se ferait mieux de renoncer
je suis sincère et désintéressée souvent
des gens très ça c'est à d'autres très
intéressé c'est comme si je regarde si
je regarde indépendamment de l'homme
françois hollande
si je regarde l'intérêt de la gauche
puisque certains je le comprends on
pense à l'intérêt de la gauche
l'intérêt de la gauche c'est que
françois hollande soit de nouveau le
candidat parce que c'est celui quelles
que soient les commentaires du jour du
lendemain ou de la veille
c'est celui qui a le plus de capacité à
rassembler la gauche
quelles que soient les critiques quelles
que soient les insatisfactions même si
je regarde s'ils ont aimé mais les
déceptions sont une chose il faut les
regarder comme tel il faut les analyser
comme tel il faut les respecter comme
tel il faut leur apporter des éléments
d'explication et du monde espoirs il
s'agit pas de dire les français sont
heureux ils demandent qu'une seule chose
non roy il faut regarder la réalité en
face mais moi je compare la politique
c'est pas simplement de regarder
quelqu'un c'est aussi de comparer aux
autres et quand je compare aux autres
candidats de gauche
je n'en vois aucun qui soit mieux placé
que françois hollande pour rassembler au
premier tour et évidemment c'est le
glyphe rassembler au 2e manuel valls qui
a beaucoup modifier son discours ces
dernières semaines qui samedi dernier
débat s'est présentée quand même un
homme de rassemblement on va l'écouter
joue désormais effectivement lu ce prix
vous avez raison la carte du
rassemblement alors moi je veux que
chacun se pose les bonnes questions
il se demande arnaud à benoît aurélie à
emmanuel patois l'autre
qu'est ce qui nous sépare bien sûr je
connais notre débat mais au fond qu'est
ce qui nous rapproche
d'abord d'avoir gouverné ensemble avec
le président la république et des
valeurs des valeurs celles de la
république lui aussi s'avance au nom du
rassemblement il est même soutenu on l'a
compris il a presque reçu l'aval de jean
christophe cambadélis le papa tu
mangeais partie était alors et claude
naturel a parlé d'un problème
d'incarnation de ce matin or voici prend
les choses dans l'ordre
donc le premier ministre qui est
aujourd'hui soutenue par une majorité de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale
on l'a vu encore avec le dernier vote
sur le parlement il ya une majorité
majorité absolue de vote pour bon il est
soutenu par une majorité de gauche et il
se comporte en rassembleur de la gauche
je dirais c'est c'est bien tant mieux
puisqu'il va falloir rassembler et il
est avec la loyauté qu'on lui connaît et
la loyauté qui le décrit avec sincérité
a souhaité que le prix dans la
république puisse être le candidat qui
représente cette gauche donc on est donc
il n'a pas univers une note
bon alors vous lisiez à la tête moi je
vais vous demander quelle est votre idée
derrière la tête non je vous écoute et
j'analyse que vous ne dites pas ce que
vous avez derrière la tête a mis
d'accord que sa loyauté
cette avancée qui causé l'arrière penser
à moi je regarde la colo j contre la
laïcité l'adoucissant discours bbc moi
je ne vais pas m'en plaindre je vais
vous dire les choses très simplement je
préfère largement le discours là sur le
rassemblement qui est au nom de quoi qui
est pas ou non formelle qui est vous
avez participé à la gestion de la france
ceux qui appartiennent à cette gauche
qui est prête à prendre des
responsabilités même si à un moment
donné il peut y avoir des désaccords
vous qui savez que rien ne se fait en un
jour
rien ne se faire en un soir que le coup
du grand soir et le lendemain matin on
se réveille heureux ça n'existe pas que
il faut prendre les choses à bras le
corps qu'il faut mettre les mains dans
le cambouis tous ceux là qui ont mis les
mains dans le cambouis
vous vous
vous rassemblez vous donc de cette
mesure mais il a fait flop flop vient se
faire plaquer vous le passé c'est que sa
basse et flops
sinon vous ne vous le présenter samedi
comme quelque chose d'important
donc je préfère je vais jusqu'au bout de
la phrase je préfère ce discours de
rassemblement
à un moment donné une phrase peut-être
lui a échappé qui disait il ya deux
gauches irréconciliables pour moi je
pense qu'il ya pas de gauches
irréconciliables
il ya une gauche difficile rassembler
très difficiles à rassembler et dans les
comptes le contexte d'aujourd'hui
extrêmement difficiles à rassembler mais
la gauche peut se rassembler non
seulement ça elle doit se rassembler
elle est aujourd'hui certains ont
utilisé le terme pulvérisé en poussière
parce qu'il ya plein de petits morceaux
partout et la tâche qui est la nôtre
la tâche du président la tâche du
premier ministre c'est de faire en sorte
de cette vision éclatée de la gauche on
ait une vision un peu plus rassembler je
suis pas je sais très bien qu'il restera
des cassures qui restera des
concurrences mais il faut rassembler
cette gauche parce que le seul moyen
pour que les français est un choix qui
ne soient pas réduits entre la droite et
l'extrême droite c'est de faire en sorte
que la gauche soit présente au deuxième
tour de cette élection présidentielle ne
sera pas présent vous l'avez dit et
c'était le reflet par exemple à présent
décret elle sera pas présente
s'il ya une cassure aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui la priorité les chèques
mais qu'elle se veut dire intériorisé
décès je ferai pas de la politique si je
considère avec la situation
d'aujourd'hui était immuable
la politique c'est de faire bouger les
lignes et les lignes peuvent bouger les
lignes doivent bouger et ils bougeront
au cours des des semaines et des mois
qui viennent
est-ce qu'elle bougeront suffisamment
personne n'en sait rien mais elles vont
bouger et nous sommes là pour faire
bouger ces lignes vous vous parliez de
loyauté est
et de rassemblement est ce que la
démarche des manuels macron fait partie
d'une part de la loyauté et d'autre part
du rassemblement est ce que ce n'est pas
dangereux compris pour une candidature
de françois hollande oui je pense que
tout ça va revenir dans l'ordre si je
puis dire chacun va c'est qu'il voir
apprécié pouvoir apprécier qu'elle est
là le poids exact des uns et des autres
au delà de la nouveauté au delà
d'intelligence au delà des qualités qui
sont réelles chez tel ou tel est en
partie caché chez emmanuel macron moi je
dis pour rassembler la gauche je dis pas
je fais aucune différence entre la
droite et la gauche où je suis nulle
part être nulle part ça peut attirer la
bienveillance pendant quelques semaines
mais il ya un moment donné j'ai employé
l'expression il faut redescendre sur
terre et sur terre en politique en
france il ya une droite et une gauche
qui sont pas séparés surtout il ya bien
des sujets sur lesquels la droite et la
gauche peuvent agir ensemble dans le
même schéma internationale pour soutien
aux armées pour un season la défense
rassemble de grands principes eux
républicain par rapport par exemple à
l'extrême droite même s'il ya une partie
de la droite qui est tenté de faire
toujours la course avec l'extrême anti
compris sur les principes républicains
mais il ya la gauche et la droite et on
a un système électoral les
présidentielles et législatives qui est
un système majoritaire à deux tours avec
un système majoritaire à deux tours
vous avez deux camps et il vaut mieux
appartenir à l'un ou appartenir à
l'autre si on veut tout dernièrement et
je vais faire quelque chose pour le bien
des fois que vous pouvez l'arrêter un
maquereau mais c'est pas à nous et je
pense que ça va être à tout seul à
vraiment qui s'arrêtera il ira jusqu'au
bout de ce qu'il voudra mais il ya un
moment où dès lors qu'on rentre dans le
domaine des choses sérieuses où en est
la gauche est ce que la gauche peut
bouger ce qu'elle peut faire face aux
difficultés considérables qu'elles
rencontrent aujourd'hui ou non et quand
on se pose cette question là à ce moment
là aller on est revenus sur terre et on
appartient
allah ou à l'autre on n'est pas ailleurs
eh bien ça a été tellement tikal je sais
pas s'il faut dire cela j'en sais rien
moi la loi yeux je souhaite aux loyauté
il avait cette qualité existait il en
aurait fait preuve plus tôt mais non
mais parce qu'il ya des forces
politiques à des rapports de force
il ya des réalités et les réalités
finissent par s'imposer alors l'uci lui
rappeler que vous êtes un ami très
ancien de françois hollande et certains
de ses amis aujourd'hui comme l'avocat
jean pierre mignard lui dit notamment
lui mais il y en a d'autres
ségolène royal n'y va pas en 2017 tu va
subir une humiliation vovo lui dit vas-y
au risque d'une humiliation mais la
décision
elle n'est pas prise par un ami aussi
intime soit il je dirais même il vaut
mieux pas être un ami hatim pour vous
conseiller quelque chose dans ce cas là
parce qu'on prend en considération
d'autres éléments que les éléments
caractère politique et de ce qu'est ce
qui peut être bon pour la gauche qui m'a
sujet quand on est de gauche mais qu'est
ce qui peut être bon pour la france qui
est un sujet fondamental quand on est
français ce qui est notre cas
donc moi je ne suis pas un ami qui donne
des conseils d'amis d'accord je fais une
analyse politique et au lundi ce
politique elle me fait dire aujourd'hui
que françois hollande est le candidat le
plus apte à rassembler la gauche et donc
à défendre les couleurs de la gauche aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
merci et lucile dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames s de public sénat
bonsoir michael bon sang mais c'est au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
alors doute est ce que la droite a le
remède pour sauver l'économie française
sur nos croix françois fillon retraite à
65 ans les 39 heures et si c'était la
bonne formule alors j'aurai une première
tendance de dire mais si ça avait été la
bonne formule ça se serait vu ça aurait
déjà donné des bons réseaux palais
jusque là et c'est exactement ce que je
me dis c'est que ovo ils ne sont pas
allés jusque là aujourd'hui nous avons
une droite qui dit clairement ce qu'elle
veut faire du point de vue économique et
social les ce qu'elle appelle des
réformes
moi ce que j'appellerai les cassures
qu'elle soit la plus faible sur wii sont
des cassures parce que là je n'avais en
bois la réforme elle est indispensable
moi je suis réformiste parce que je sais
très bien qu'on ne peut pas protéger par
exemple notre système social
si on ne fait pas évoluer sur le
différencie des soir parfois certains à
gauche ou à l'ultra gauche qui disent
pour rien touché pour rien bouger ça va
te tenir tout seul non ça ne tient pas
tout seul un système de sécurité sociale
santé de vieillesse pour le faire
évoluer au gré de l'évolution de
l'économie alors société mais pas la
cassure quand les jeux pan cette droite
là elle nous dit je vais faire et je me
fiche des corps intermédiaires et pire
encore des syndicats ça dépend quel
candidat s'il dudus toussaint alain
juppé qui est prêt à discuter notamment
sur l'application de 29 heures au
terrain des entreprises
je n'ai pas tout bien compris parce que
je finis pas pu savoir quelles sont les
différences entre les uns et les autres
mais moi j'ai compris une chose j'ai
compris une chose quand j'écoute de
nicolas sarkozy quand j'écoute françois
fillon quand j'écoute walhalla bien
nombre d'autres l'idée suivant laquelle
il faut faire en passant en force c'est
une idée qui les rassemble l'idée serait
il faut faire en force faire en force
moi c'est pas ma vision des choses ne
disent pas ça exactement non ils disent
y'en a essayé de la dictature de la cgt
on entend ça des syndicats plutôt voilà
donc passer en force c'est cet été
reportée par une partie du monde
économique ou patronal ultralibérale qui
considère que la réforme le compromis
c'est perdre du temps non une société
elle ne se réforme pas en force
elle se casse quand on passe en force et
j'ai dit récemment alain juppé devrait
s'en souvenir
parce qu'il a voulu une fois passer en
force sur une réforme qui était
peut-être nécessaire par ailleurs et il
s'est cassé les dents
et s'il a fallu d'autres y compris nous
pourraient s'intéresser en partie d'un
accord passé en france par rapport à
l'ensemble des partis et organisations
syndicales nous met sur la loi sur le
travail vous êtes un petit peu passer en
force
si vous voulez dire essai en force 7
49.43 quand ce n'est pas les élections
syndicales sur la loi travailler plus
encore sur d'autres réformes précédentes
nous avions avec nous des organisations
syndicales qui sont par ailleurs
majoritaire le monde syndical français
il est partagé
quand je dis il faut dialoguer je dis
pas qu'on fout se mettent d'accord avec
tout le monde
ça ce serait se mettre entre les mains
d'un seul d'un seul groupe mais il faut
moi c'est ma position
rechercher des accords majoritaires que
ce soit au niveau national quand on veut
faire bouger les règles nationales où
que ce soit au niveau des entreprises
lorsqu'il s'agit d'adapter la lame une
fusion a dit laurence donc entre le
programme de nicolas sarkozy
j'ai un petit peu de mal je pense qu'ils
vont essayer de faire rejouer cette
différence parce qu'il ya des primaires
parce que il faut récupérer les
centristes ce sont des jeux très
compliqué je ne comprends pas totalement
et complètement mais bon c'est l'heure
c'est leur affaire
je regardais il ya une grande qu'il ya
plein de sujets sur lesquels n'y a pas
forcément convergence mais sur cette
question économique et social il ya une
très grande trouver un jeu pendant un
autre exemple qui apparaîtra plus
lointain que ce que je viens de dire on
revient de parler des déficits on vient
de paris qu'elle est qu'est ce que
j'entends à droite c'est en main c'est
pas grave le déficit il ya qu'à laisser
partir le déficit il ya qu'a laissé
partir défier on vient de faire tous ses
efforts certains m'ont critiqué
messieurs pécresse a auparavant en
disant vous n'avez pas fait suffisamment
d'efforts vous n'avez pas fait
d'humilier si fusion des 3 % non plus
vous l'avez pas respectés par quatre on
est en train de tracer prix dans ses
deux res
mais ça ne se respectent pas la première
année a donc
la droite mais pas du tout au début au
début voilà la menace vraiment pourquoi
vous dites des choses qu'ils paient pas
et qu est-ce qu il ya une année où nous
avons fait augmenter le déficit à 5% et
chaque année ça a diminué et les 3%
c'est pas dès la première année
ou alors vous massacrer tout on ne
serait pas avec nombre de chômeurs
aurait la droite on va les filets de la
droite dit allez on y va c'est pas grave
elle et 4% 4 et demi 4,6 en contrepartie
cela ils le disent quoi la contrepartie
les réformes de structure mais enfin
deux structures elles ont en effet tout
de suite bon j'en sais quelque chose
pour calmer les réformes de structure
est calme et ça c'est une vision des
choses a encore très étrange l'on peut
en parler de ça mais les réformes de
structures qu'on nous en savons quelque
chose ça met du temps on a mis en place
des réformes de structure et le chômage
baisse très tard certains diraient trop
tard mais ça baisse ça baisse pourquoi
parce qu'il ya eu des réformes de
structure par exemple dans le
financement de des entreprises dans les
charges des entreprises parce qu'il ya
eu une loi que je connais bien qui a été
le fruit d'un accord entre partenaires
sociaux qui à l'été en 2013 a permis de
donner de souplesse sur le marché du
travail sur les déficits la droite et
encore une fois vous si vous me
permettez ils disent que si jamais ils
reviennent au pouvoir ils verront les
résultats de votre budget les déficits
sort auro explosé mais comment peut-on
dire l'édifice auront explosé personne
ne dit l'édifice vont être plus élevé
que en 2009 au juste enfin tu restes un
tout petit peu sérieux donc 5% en 2011
cette année 3 3% personne ne conteste
que nous atteindrons nos objectifs et
pour l'année prochaine mais on peut
toujours contester l'année voilà et
d'après ma femme nous prenons nous
prenons tous les moyens détroit 2 7% et
en dessous des 3% ou en voilà c'est un
chemin qui est un chemin qui est
raisonnable et tout d'un coup vous avez
la droite qui passe pour être sérieuse
et qui vous dit ah ben non je m'en fiche
les déficits les françaises iront moi je
me suis peut-être du déficit mais
derrière le déficit y à quoi il faut
financer ce déficit
derrière le déficit il ya le l'emprunt
et de l'emprunt il faut bien l'ordre
mais c'est pas c'est même pas 7
qu'irresponsable pas raisonnable ce
serait presque faire un compliment c'est
totalement un haut responsable à la
droite nous a rien aujourd'hui une
droite qui porte un projet économique
avec ses conséquences budgétaires qui me
paraît être irresponsable socialement
parce que c'est des cassures et des
ruptures et dans ces cas là la france
elle se crispe quand vous voulez passer
en force
vous faites là le glorieux pendant
quelques mois vous dit j'y vais j'y vais
envoyer
je vais aller à bruxelles je veux leur
dire que je fais comme ça je vais aller
devant les français je veux dire on y va
en force mais au bout de pas très
longtemps
ça se crise ça se bloque et ya plus de
réformes
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut faire
avancer la france j'attendais la
responsable du social où s'exprimera si
j'ai pas la rue c'est la société qui se
crispe promet-elle en fait les gens qui
se crise mais c'est pas faux mais
l'enfer c'est pas nous qui déciderons
ils ont connu l'enfer quand ils ont
voulu passer en force sur un certain
nombre de réformes est par contre quand
ils sont passés dans le dialogue
je le dis pour des réformes de droite
comme pour les nôtres quand ils sont
passés dans le dialogue
il ya eu des réformes et des réformes
durables des réformes qui ne sont pas
remises en cause des réformes qui
produisent leurs effets donc c'est une
politique irresponsable socialement
parce que c'est une politique de
cassures et de rupture et si possible
responsable du point de vue des finances
publiques parce qu'alors relancer les
difficiles aujourd'hui après tous les
efforts qui ont été demandés par les
français et par eux avant 2012 et par
nous depuis 2012
franchement c'est un sacré gâchis alors
est-ce de la question sociale que de
vouloir revenir sur les 35 heures
écouter michel sapin françois fillon et
justifie la fin des 35 heures il
explique en fait qu'il s'agirait pour
lui pour la droite de revenir à une
situation il ya une quinzaine d'années
que personne ne contestait à l'époque ça
consisterait juste à revenir à la
situation qui était un lieu il ya quinze
ans voilà je rappelle qu'on travaillait
39 heures au travail et même 40 heures
quand on travaillait 39 heures en france
avant 2000
les salariés de défilé pas dans la rue
pour réclamer les 35 heures les 35
heures c'est une invention du
gouvernement
et socialiste de l'époque parce qu'il
pensait que c'était un instrument de
lutte contre le chômage mais n'y avait
pas de revendication des salariés pour
passer tout de même un seul shaker c'est
drôle parce qu'il a aucune mémoire il y
avait des gens qui défilaient dans la
rue pour demander les 35 heures
sébastien hinault vieille revendication
syndicale que de passage à 35 heures
vous le savez très bien donc il ya une
espèce de manque de mémoire pour
faciliter son raisonnement
mais la question avait pas tellement là
donc il veut passer de 35 heures à 39
heures en étant payés comment 35 heures
oui c'est ça sa proposition sa
proposition
c'est ça sa proposition ou si je regarde
d'autres pleins de contradictions je
prendrais sarkozy sait on supprime les
heures supplémentaires
et d'ailleurs on a une autre proposition
dans une autre page du livre qui dit on
défiscalise les heures supplémentaires
quand vous supprimer des heures
supplémentaires une idée très difficile
de l'édifice caliséo de nuit la réalité
des choses à vous poser un an mais la
réalité des choses c'est que la
proposition sur ce point là c'est de
faire travailler les gens plus longtemps
sans les payer plus c'est exactement ce
qu'on appelle une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat visant les dons l'ordonance
alors mis en accusation est contente
très courte
après le refus de la wallonie de
ratifier l'accord de libre échange entre
l'europe et le canada est ce que cet
accord qui est mort
j'espère que non je pense que c'est un
accord qui ait un accord de bonne
qualité il faut l'expliquer parce qu'il
ya toujours un parieur il ya des jeux
par an pendant les cinq secondes mais
c'est je pense c'est un accord de
qualité il faut qu'il soit discuté
suivant les règles qu'on fait n'est pas
morale de chacun des pays je l'espère
que j'espère que non ce serait dommage
qu'il soit mort parce qu'il apporterait
un mieux au français il apporterait un
mieux au français il sait pas danger
c'est tant mieux pour les français
celui-là parce que pas l'autre parce que
celui là il est d'une meilleure qualité
il a été beaucoup mieux négocier il a
permis de respecter à ce genre de choses
et services publics la culture
l'environnement je veux pas rentrer sur
tous les détails alors que celui qui est
en cours de négociation avec les états
unis et d'une autre qualité enfin
publiquement il n'a pas la même qualité
rageant de voir la wallonie il a imposé
sa loi à 500 millions d'euros quand on
sait les règles c'est des règles
constitutionnel de chacun des pays je ne
vais pas les critiquer mais je pense
qu'il serait meilleur pour tout le monde
y compris pour la wallonie que cet
accord puisse être signé
merci beaucoup michel soient plaints
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir mais klm
penseurs à tous a très vite on se
retrouve dans 15 jours maintenant